it's about our ability to communicate
ideas honestly with each other without
algorithmic manipulation being able to
say what we think is right being able to
challenge the system being able to
communicate with other people without
thinking that the government is actually
reading all of our texts and all of
those things
and Russell Brand was on Bill Maher's
podcast which debuted last night and
they talked about Free Speech they
talked about Rumble and this Dave Rubin
guy so I had to throw this in
what is Rumble now I'm sorry
media uh stupid it's essentially a
competitor to YouTube which has made its
raison d'etre non-censorship that has
been taken up initially by a lot of
right like you'd have to say a
right-wing uh voices uh but is doesn't
have any skin in the game with regard to
like all the kind of content that is put
out except for that you continue to own
your content and you know you can say
what you want you can talk about what
you want and like for me like freedom of
speech doesn't mean freedom of speech is
a group condemn and criticize people it
means freedom of speech to attack
establishment and look for ways to bring
people together David Rubin Dave rubin's
on there yeah I know Dave's been on this
at his company though but they've owned
I believe locals which is the sort of
membership aspect of Rumble which is
essentially like YouTube he's been here
love love I love him yeah he's a great
guy yeah and we don't agree politically
no but but we laugh about it it's it's
it's yeah and the here's the problem
with Where We Are
media wise as it especially Free Speech
you know as Comics we adore free speech
I it's it's my life blood I couldn't be
there I'm so grateful to the people who
came before me who were Martyrs for free
speech you know there was no doubt in my
mind who the champions of free speech
were and and also the threat and the
threat was all on the right yeah and the
Champions were on the left and that's
not how I feel now so when people say
like oh why are you harder on the left
well that's one of the big reasons I
just mentioned Lenny Bruce so I'm going
to say that that's a sign from the
universe and by the way Dave rubin's
always trying to convince me about the
universe which I find amusing but um I'm
going to pretend there's such a thing is
the universe
and say that uh Lenny Bruce you know he
forgot to like be an Entertainer because
he was so passionate right I don't want
that to happen to you I don't think it
will it never has you proved that like
not just here but on real time today it
was just like you know you bring it man
and just uh that's you know I don't know
why I'm anointing myself as the person
to give you advice you probably don't
need but what if instead of trying to
convert Bill Maher anymore on which way
he should vote I I've made my point I
think you guys get my point and
hopefully bill will come around I'm sort
of losing hope to a certain degree and
Bill I appreciate and I I thank you for
the kind words what if really because as
he said Dave rubin's always trying to
get me to believe in the universe what
if my real goal now with Bill Maher
should be that he will one day do a
prageru video why I left atheism maybe
that will be the Dave Rubin as we roll
into Passover and Easter maybe that's
the Dave Rubin shift because there are
things happening in the universe and we
are connected in ways that we cannot
fully understand and you end up as a
Believer whether you believe it or not
but that's a whole other topic for a
whole other show
thank you
[Music]